the right man is on the hill for the
rockies for the second straight opening
day it is hermann marcus and he'll face
one of the games great players in fuki
bets right out of the gate
leading the season off and hitting a
high fly ball that will sink into the
left in front of rymel tapia
a leadoff hit for mookie betts not so
much a high fly ball as a humpback liner
but a leadoff hit nonetheless then up
comes corey seeger
he goes after it and swats it to left
base hit
you've done your homework on and you've
watched a little corey seeger over the
years just a few at bats
one two and it softly hit the fuentes on
the bag for one on the first double play
i know my cousin could make that play
and so can i well last year the rockies
turned 78 double plays and you couldn't
have asked for a better double play ball
right now than this one off the bat of
justin turner it's so easy as a third
base when you just step on the bag and
the great thing about it too is you can
step on the bag with your right foot on
the subaru super motor notice what he
does josh knows that he has plenty of
time with turning around and so just
make a strong throw over to first you
don't have 2-2
and this will get hermione off the field
the rockies off the field unscathed
double play helped out
clayton kershaw eight opening day starts
the single best era in baseball history
for anybody that's thrown at least 40
innings and ahead of a few hall of
famers on that list first one to josh
fuentes
[Music]
nice play of third by turner and a nice
stretch by muncie
the stellar play down here by justin
turner he decides to get rid of it
really quick not completely square his
feet up
planning on the bounce throw probably
planning on it being a little bit more
right at max muncie but muncie with some
sweet footwork over at first
to stretch and get that one and stay on
the bag
story at first
toss over there story's going to take
off andy zao
muncie quickly got rid of it and seeger
dropped the tag to finish the inning
bellinger hits a high fly ball left
center field back towards the wall it is
gone
just over the wall a two run home run
tapia might have gotten a piece but it
still escaped the yard
what is mellinger waiting on
[Applause]
all kinds of confusion going here
you know the umpires are coming together
to discuss it dave roberts is coming out
of the dugout it's a home run
i wonder if cody crossed
justin turner
if that happens
that does the passing is out so
ballinger's going to be out from that
point the play continues
wow in and out of his glove and then
bellinger passes turn around the bases
so bellinger's going to be the second
out of the inning turner will be
wherever he wound up when the play ended
so we know there's two outs because
we're still playing the inning so yeah
it's one nothing dodgers
one two on owings
and that's lofted to fairly deep right
field bets now chasing it and he's not
gonna be able to make the play owings
around second he runs well he's on his
way to third with a fly ball triple that
honestly i think was misjudged by one of
the game's best outfielders in mookie
becks
guarding against the bun at first base
is muncie and the bunt's coming anyhow
muncie coming to get it's not going to
have a play base hit run scores tie ball
game hanson stared at months he said i
don't care i'm going to push a button
that direction anyhow well played
garrett hampson and that is the kind of
baseball
that the rockies are gonna have to play
some of at least in 2021 garrett says
okay i'm not gonna go anywhere else but
first base i'm gonna put the pressure on
muncie because max the only play he had
was to try to bare hand that and come
home because as you can see clayton and
max are right there together
and garrett was going to be able to beat
it out even if he decided not to go home
tied at one hamson at second with two
outs this is gonna get into left center
field around third comes garrett hampson
josh fuentes keeps hitting and the
rockies have a two-to-one lead
spilly he stayed on that breaking ball
well what's impressive about josh is
he's always been a high contact rate
even with two strikes
bellinger will lead it off against
gonzalez
that's a little flared on the left field
line and he's been on all three times
he's hustling his way to second and
beating tapia's throw
leadoff double for cody bellinger
lux with the line drive base hit to tie
the game
lux's first hit of the season brings
home bellinger and it's 2-2 in the fifth
congratulations gavin lux on his first
rbi of the 20-21 season
yes it ties the game
but even more importantly it lengthens
the dodger lineup
[Applause]
now with one out infield's back
conceding the run second and third great
speed aboard and great speed at the
plate in tapia and tapia gets on it on
the ground he's going to get the run in
well done
well done owen scores hampton to third
rbi for rymel tapia rockies lead it
three to two in the fifth
oh two
and it's on the ground to short and it's
under the glove of seeger
and the rockies have a fourth rod
corey seeger just had that one run right
under his glove on a routine ground ball
and the rockies are plus two on the
scoreboard corey seeger ate eight airs
last year
and this is one where
just really surprised but
again good things happen when you just
put the ball in play
0-1
fly ball center field
playable for garrett hampson but it will
bring home kershaw from third and it's a
4-3 game
[Applause]
line drive base hit to right
blackman's up to get it his throw will
go to third as bets comes for the plate
seeger diving he's out
and the inning is over but the game is
tied
two out rbi single from max muncie the
dodgers get a pair in the sixth
that's what the dodgers think is going
to happen
hit up the middle cj crone gets a green
light he's coming home throw going to
third d is safe there chris owens coming
through
here come the rockies again the bottom
part of the lineup today and i'm talking
about chris owings that's three hits and
rbi the guy coming up next garrett
hampson base hit a walk they've scored
four runs
gaza can run it first this is going to
find a way through the left side it's
going to bring a run home here comes
owings to the plate
rymel tapia coming through
six to four colorado
they get those two runs right back so
with two outs in the sixth inning
clayton kershaw will walk off at 20th
and blake down by two
and this is up the middle diving stop
there's one on to first get first by
crown
double play
how do you like that one
third turn of the day for the rockies
and that one was special
great play by owings who's had a
spectacular afternoon on both sides
of the baseball
blackman at third crown at second one
out in the home half of the seventh with
the rockies leading the dodgers six to
four
to the backstop here comes charlie
and barnes can't handle it
rockies lead at seven of four on the
wild pitch
look out that to the back stop here
comes crone and the dive toward the
plate safe
cj crone beat barnes
the rockies have a four run lead in the
seventh
[Applause]
seeger slices a liner to left center
field an rbi hit for seeger it's eight
five
two hits two walks
and on rbi for seeger
well it'll come down to this
confrontation daniel bard against
the great mookie bets
soft liner gloved in the air ball game
over the rockies
have opened up the 20-21 campaign at
coors field
with a beautiful 8-5 victory over the
defending world champion dodgers